OKAY, SO SOMETHING CAUGHT MY
EYE THIS WEEK.
DID YOU SEE THIS?
AN OFFICIAL MEETING IN EUROPE
IS THE CLIMATE GROUP THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP PULLED OUT
OF.
>> IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
ERADICATING POVERTY AND
PROVIDING UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
RELIABLE ENERGY, IT IS CLEAR
THAT ENERGY INNOVATION AND
FOSSIL FUELS WILL CONTINUE TO
PLAY A LEADING ROLE.
[LAUGHTER]
VERY STRANGE.
YOU KNOW HOW PAYMENT CHANGE
ACTIVISTS NEVER STOP GOING ON
ABOUT LEAVING THE SCIENCE AND
HEALTH FACTS MATTER.
THE MYRON FATE CHEERING THE
UNITED STATES INSTEAD OF
JEERING.
IN THE EVIL POPULACE TRUMP
AMERICA, HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED
TO CARBON EMISSIONS IN 2017.
THEY FELL BUT IN THE FAINTLY
GLOBALIST EUROPEAN UNION THEY
WENT UP BY 1.15% IN THE SAME
PERIOD.
IN FACT.
CAPITA IN TRUMP'S AMERICA ARE
NEARLY AT A 70 YEAR LOW.
TURNS OUT ENERGY DEREGULATION
DOES MORE TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE THAN GOING TO
CONFERENCES.
I GUESS YOU MIGHT CALL THAT AN
INCONVENIENT TRUTH.
THIS IS PRETTY INCONVENIENT
TO.
IF YOU GO AROUND SAYING TRUMP
IS A FAKE POPULACE, THAT HE'S
NOT DOING ANYTHING TO HELP THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> ALI HAD TIME FOR WAS
CELEBRITY AND NOW SUDDENLY
HE'S ACTING LIKE HE'S A
POPULACE OUT THERE.
HE'S GONNA FIGHT FOR WORKING
PEOPLE.
COME ON MAN.
>> HE'S TRYING TO TELL US HE
CARES ABOUT THE MIDDLE CLASS.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THAT'S A BUNCH OF MALARKEY.
>> MALARKEY.
I WANT TRUMP TO RUN IN 2020
JUST SO WE HEAR MORE OF THAT
WORD.
AMERICA'S POVERTY RATE WAS
LOWER IN TRUMP'S FIRST YEAR
THAN AT ANY POINT IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
OKAY, WHATEVER, BUT OF COURSE
THE MIDDLE CLASS WAS SCREWED
BY THAT TRUMP TAX CUT THAT
ONLY HELP THE RICH.
OH WAIT, THE TRUMP TAX CUT
DOUBLED THIS STANDARD
DEDUCTION TO 24000.
THAT IS A HUGE CHANGE THAT
WILL TAKE MANY OF AMERICANS
OUT OF FEDERAL INCOME TAX
ALTOGETHER.
WHAT ELSE HELPS MIDDLE-CLASS
CUSTOMER JOBS BUT OF COURSE
THAT IDIOT TRUMP COULDN'T
CREATE THEM.
>> 170 SAYS, LIKE THE PERSON
YOU JUST MENTIONED ONE THAT
CAN ADVERTISE FOR, THAT HE'S
GONNA BRING ALL THESE JOBS
BACK, HOW EXACTLY ARE YOU
GONNA DO THAT.
HE JUST SAYS ON THE NEGOTIATE
A BETTER DEAL.
HOW?
HOW EXACTLY ARE YOU GOING TO
NEGOTIATE THAT?
WHAT MAGIC WAND YOU HAVE I
DON'T KNOW, MAYBE JUST BETTER
ECONOMIC POLICY, THE KIND THAT
RESULTS IN THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE SINCE 1969
AND THE LOWEST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT
EVER.
ALSO, WASN'T TRUMP GOING TO
CRUSH THE ECONOMY THEY ALL
AGREE, DONALD TRUMP WILL DRIVE
AMERICA BACK INTO RECESSION.
>> LEFT, RIGHT AND CENTER,
INCONVENIENT TRUTH, EVEN THE
NEW YORK TIMES JUST GAVE TRUMP
CREDIT FOR THE FACT THAT THE
U.S. ECONOMY IS ON TRACK FOR
ITS BEST ANNUAL PERFORMANCE
SINCE 2005.
ALL RIGHT, WHATEVER, JOBS BUT
TRUMP STILL WASN'T DELIVERING
HIS PROMISES TO WORKING
PEOPLE.
I MEAN AFTER DECADES OF
STAGNATION, INCOMES ARE STILL
FLAT, AREN'T THEY?
WE MET FEW THINGS THAT WE BEEN
LOOKING AT FOR QUITE A WHILE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE MOVING TOO
MUCH AS WAGES.
OH DEAR, THAT TURNS OUT NOT TO
BE TRUE ANYMORE.
RAISES HAVE RISEN ALL THE WAY
THROUGH AND WE ARE UP IN THE
LAST QUARTER.
THE HIGHEST LEVEL IN A
DECADE.
FINE, BUT IT'S ALL GONNA BE
RUINED BY TRUMP'S CRAZY TRADE
WAR WITH CHINA.
THE ELITISTS SEEM TO HATE
TRUMP SO MUCH THEY EVEN TOOK
CHINA SIDE.
THEY JUST LAPTOP HIS SPEECH ON
THE VIRTUES OF GLOBALIZATION.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE EU
INVESTMENT BANK SAID, IN THESE
TIMES OF A LACK OF LEADERSHIP,
PARTICULARLY IN EUROPE, IT WAS
QUITE IMPRESSIVE, BUT WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING?
IS IT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PRESSURE IS WORKING.
CHINA IS ON THE BACK FOOT
MAKING TRADE CONCESSIONS, AND
NOW PLEDGING TO DROP IT'S MADE
IN CHINA 2025 PROGRAM WHICH
WAS THE GRAND PLAN TO ACHIEVE
WORLD DOMINATION IN THE
FUTURE.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY MEAN IT,
BUT EVEN A FACT THEY ARE
SAYING IT WAS A MAJOR VICTORY
FOR THAT IDIOT TRUMP WHO
OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
HE'S DOING.
JUST LIKE NORTH KOREA,
REMEMBER.
>> WE HAVE THE TOTAL IS 7100
INDIVIDUAL NUCLEAR WARHEAD.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THE DESTRUCTIVE CAPABILITY IS
THERE AND WERE ABOUT TO AND
THE LAUNCH ORDERS OVER TO A
GUY WHO CAN'T STAY AWAY FROM
HIS PHONE FOR 15 MINUTES.
IT WAS OUTGOING PRESIDENT
OBAMA WHO TOLD PRESIDENT TRUMP
THAT NORTH KOREA WOULD BE HIS
NUMBER ONE PROBLEM.
TRUMP ACTUALLY LISTEN TO HIM,
DID SOMETHING ABOUT IT, AND
TURNED OUR RELATIONSHIP AROUND
IN A WAY THAT HAS MADE THE
WORLD INCOMPARABLY SAFER, AND
THEN, JUST THIS WEEK WE SAW
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
SUBSTANTIVE PROGRESS FROM THIS
MINISTRATION.
MAJOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
LED BY JARED KUSHNER, A MAJOR
NEW EFFORT TO REVITALIZE URBAN
AMERICA AND REBUILD AMERICA
AND A HIGHLY SIGNIFICANT NEW
STRATEGY FROM JOHN BOLTON TO
FIGHT CHINA'S ATTEMPTED
COLONIZATION OF AFRICA.
ON TOP OF THAT AMERICA, THIS
WEEK BECOMING A NET OIL
EXPORTER FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
75 YEARS, ENABLING US TO
REDUCE THE GLOBAL INFLUENCE OF
DODGY REGIMES IN THE MIDDLE
EAST AND ELSEWHERE.
YES, BUT HE'S STILL AN IDIOT,
IS ANY.
HE STILL TRUMP.
THE POINT HERE IS THIS.
WE WILL NEVER PERSUADE THE
TRUMP HATERS ON THE LEFT AND
THE RIGHT TO CHANGE THEIR
FEELINGS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
THEY JUST CAN'T STAND HIM, BUT
MORE THAN ANYTHING, THEY FIND
HIM VULGAR, NOT TO THEIR TASTE
, FINE, BUT COULD YOU JUST
FOCUS ON THE FACTS.
COULD YOU JUST ACKNOWLEDGE FOR
A DAY OR SO OVER CHRISTMAS ON
THE FACTS, ON THE POLICY, ON